サッブパパッスアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダタナン エタングブッダナササナング
では よろしくお願いします
今日の説法会のお布施は大泉孝志さんのお布施で
この法で今日の法話を実現できています
で まあ二回分を納めていますが
今日は 3月24日の法話会になります
ですから 大泉さんの両親
親戚 親しい人々とともに
皆様方はこの大変な高い功徳ですからね
法性というのは で この功徳の力で三宝に守られて
幸せで平和で生きられますように
毎日悲しいことがなく
楽しく生活できますように
それから日々人格が向上して
心が清らかな心を作って解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
ありがとうございます
三回 サードサード サード
はい では あの ちょっと貧血で長い時間立っていられませんので
できるだけ早く 終了したいと思っています
今日のテーマはね 無我とプライドというね
ことですね 一応あの内容というかね
どんなテーマを扱うのかということは
ヴィパッサナーなどでネットなどで説明していたと思います
だからそちらに触れないで直接話に入ります
自我に囚われず自分を失うことのないブッダの中道
はい まあ自我自我と言うんだけど
まずは自我の定義をしてみましょう
自分の主観を中心にして生きることなんですね
結局 自我っていうのは
自分の考え方があって
その考え通りに生きているんですね
僕は当たり前のことなんですよ
誰だってやっていることです
だからまあ ポイントはそこで理解できると思いますよ
だから 自分の意見に基づいて自分の意見中心に生きる
どんなせいでもそのふうに生きている
だから正しいということにならないんです
そこがポイントなんです
我々は仕方がなく主観で生きているんです
実は主観ではなくて 事実に基づいて
しっかりした客観的なデータに基づいて生きていなくちゃいけないんです
これができなくなっているんですね
次の定義は この他の意見が自分の意見に合う時のみ認める
この自我中心に生きると主観で生きると
他人の意見を無視しなくてはいけないんです
これまた誰だってやっている
人の話を聞かない みんなやっているんだから別にいいんじゃないということにならないね
だからしかし 自分に意見があるんだから
人の意見は取り入れない
しかし 自分の意見と他人の意見が結構似ている
それだったら無駄があって
人の意見を聞く意味じゃないでしょ
偉そうに私はみんなの意見もちゃんと考えて
それに合わせて生きてますよと言って嘘ばっかり
みんな自分の意見と似ている人の意見を聞いているだけ
反対の意見があったら全く無視
だからそれもうまく正しくないんだけど
生命はみんなやっているんですね
それで自分の思考に性格に改良改革はほとんどない
こんなものだったら改良改革できないでしょ
まあ年を取ると変化はあるんだけど
自分の意見はすごく改良して改革して
立派な より正しい意見に達したということはないんです
ただ そのまま生まれて流れて
老いて年取って病気になって死んでしまうという
まあこのワンパターンのサイクルでみんな生きているんですね
他を抑える 支配する生き方をするから
平等という考えがない
ただ これ 自我のある人にとってはみんな平等ということはないんですね
自分と違う意見を言っている人は潰したいんですね
自分と似ている意見を持っている人は
自分の仲間にして それをまた支配したい
だからなんでこの人類を見ると何かしら人を抑えたいんですね
周りの人々 会社の人々
家族の人々 みんなを抑えたくなっているんですね
みんなできるかできないか関係なく
もうボスになりたいんですね
だから母親は子供と旦那のボスになりたがっているんだけど
子供も子供なりに家のボスになりたがっているんです
それも一つのこの自我
あるいは主観で生きている時は出てくる問題なんです
それをみんなやっています
みんなボスになりたいんです
だからみんな平等でしょう
みんなにも同じ悩み 苦しみがあるでしょうというふうな考えは
自我ある人には現れないんです
人は本来自我中心的です
結局は生命は人だけじゃなくて
誰だってこの恐ろしい問題抱えているんです
自我中心的という だからいくら世の中で説教しても
歌ってもね みんな仲良し
兄弟のようにとかね 親子のようにとか
そんなことはありえないんです
みんな平等で嘘ばっかり
口先だけ 実際の生き方はみんな自我で生きているんです
じゃあ 自我の強度 自我って言ってもこの強弱があるんです
人によって自我の強さが変わります
自我の強い人は 自我が弱い人を支配します
こんなの難しい話じゃないね
我が強い人々はいつでも弱い人々を抑えておくんです
弱い人の人権 尊厳を奪います
これはほとんどの国々であることでね
弱い人には まあ尊厳ないね
やられっぱなしで蹴なられて
生きることになっちゃうんです
まあいろんな 人を自我を張るかもしれません
私は勉強しているんだ
知識人だ 社長だ 部長だ
課長だとかね 国会議員だとかね
金持ちだとかね そういう何かのとんでもない言い訳して自我を張るかもしれません
それによって他を非難
侮辱をしているんですね
だから非難 侮辱 いじめ
受けるのは自分の自我が弱いからなんです
宗教の世界で開祖 神 仏様が現れます
これ宗教の世界といったら
もう開祖様は神様は仏様
どんなくだらない単語でも何か作って
この我の絶対的そういう存在を作って
そちらから潰すんです
人々を 政治世界で独裁者が現れます
あまりにも我が強い人がいると
他の人々より この人は政治活動に参加しているならば
何のことなく独裁者になるんです
全部潰しますよ 潰して潰して独裁者になって終わっちゃうんです
今の強い人の話ばっかりしましたけどね
均等の強さの自我ってあるんですかと
これは大体ないんですよ
我々の自我っていうのは
それぞれ個人に個人に合わせて強さが変わります
ですから 自我イコール個なので
ほとんど均等にならないと思います
まあ生命は無数だからね
いくら探せば均等の自我の強さを持ってる人々はいくらでも見つかると思いますけど
まぁ論理的には自我とは個なんですね
個人なんですね ですから
それは平等じゃないんです
均等じゃないんですね
しかし ある社会で生きる人々の自我意識がほとんど似ていると仮定しましょう
そんな仮定しなくても
大体ヨーロッパの国々とかね
スイスとかね そういうそこら辺の国々では大体みんな平等なんですね
ドイツ フランス イタリアはちょっとどうかなと
ちょっとわからないんだけど
他のヨーロッパの国々の場合はもう誰だって平等で
まあ王がいたっても誰も気にしないし
その人のスーパーに行って買い物したっても
別に警備もないし まあそういうふうな
この本当にできるだけ平等な社会を作っている
それも最近なんですけど
社会はあるんで ただ そういうふうな
この誰だって自我が平等な強さを持っているというふうに考えたら
皆同じ力で自我を張るから
多数の賛成でなければ何も実行できなくなる
これ 国と取っちゃうと難しいんだからね
例えば 40人のグループだとしますよ
である 何だらかんだら会を作って
40人がメンバーたちがいる
みんなの自我は同じ 強さが同じなんですね
だからギャーギャーと自分の意見言っちゃうでしょ
40人も言うんです そうなってくると何もできなくなりますね
それでやっと多数の意見を通じるようになるんです
この裏の意味わかりますかね
多数の意見というのは世に言う民主主義でしょ
だから同じ強度の同じ強さの自我がないと民主主義は成り立たないんです
その民主主義も結局は多数の見解であって
すべての見解ではないんです
だから たとえ民主主義な世界であっても
潰される自我があるんですね
無視される生命がいるんです
今 世にある民主主義はその結果ですね
今いくらか民主主義という形がありますけど
それは結構みんな自我張ってますからなんです
自我が張れなくなっちゃうと
自分を主張しなくなっちゃうと
民主主義はなくなります
どうかどうかご自由にお偉い方々やってくださいと言っちゃうと
もう完璧にやられますよ
だからなんだあんたはという態度がある限り
なんとなくお互い怖くて
民主主義というものは現れます
民主主義は他の政治システムよりはよろしいでしょう
だってたくさん人々の意見に従ってますからね
それで 自我の世界で民主主義はない
平等という考えもない
それでも自我の強度によって
なんとなく二次的な結果として
独裁者 民主主義といういろんなものは現れてはくるんです
これは政府だけじゃなくて
国だけじゃなくて 家族の中でも同じ
学校の中でも クラスの中でも
そういう現象は見えてくるんです
クラスでクラスであっても
一人がすごい自我が強い生徒がいたら
その人は独裁的に押さえるんです
で クラスの中で気が弱い人々の権利は全く聞かなくなっちゃいます
はい そういうことで この理想の民主主義というものはあるんでしょうかと
完全な民主主義 完全な民主主義っていうのは
メンバーすべての意見通る時なんです
これってありえないね
40人のグループで私も同じ意見
私も同じ意見 私も同じ意見ということにはならないんです
だから 俗世間では正しい民主主義っていうのはありえないんです
人間には自分の意見 主観あるんです
人間には自分自身の感情があるんです
人間には自分自身の判断方法があるんです
だったら 理想の民主主義はさよならなんです
だから 理想的な民主主義のために必要なのは何でしたっけね
自我がないことなんです
自分の主観 自分個人の感情
好み 好き好き嫌い そういうのはない方が
理想的な民主主義社会出来上がります
そうするとみんな同意見になります
俗世間では実現できない
難しい 理想の民主主義
自分の意見ではなく 真理の導き導かされるようにしなさいとブッダが比丘サンガに説かれたんです
そこでブッダが自分の弟子たちにね
あなた方の意見はね ゴミ箱に捨てなさいと
真理があるんだよと 事実
この事実に従って真理に従って生活しなさいと
それは真理はダンマ ヴィパッサナーと二つに分けてあって
ダンマは真理 ヴィネーは生き方
正しい生き方があります
それに人の個人的な見解は関係ないんです
だから個人の見解っていうのはどうしても間違っているんだから
主観だからね それではなく
真理 客観的な真理と生き方
真理は考えるために 生き方は生きるために
ダンマ ヴィネー そういうふうに生きてみなさいと出家させるんです
だから出家した比丘は自我入っちゃうと
これは違反なんです だから自我張らないんです
私はこんな意見だからとかね
言わないんです だから比丘サンガの場合は
真理はどうなっているのか
戒律ヴィネーではどのように説かれているのか
経典でどのように説かれているのかということだけ調べて
あ これ我々やっていることはちょっと良くない
そうすると 40人のグループで
例えば 12人 ちょっと間違った生き方をしていて
そこで真理に合わせてみたら
自分たちの生き方は間違っていると
ああ 間違っているんだと本人たちが理解するんです
それでではやめましょうということは
万場一致で通るんです
やめるしかない 一人の人がこんなこと言ったって
私は自分ではこんなことやってもいいやと思いますよとかね
私にも自由があるんだからやりますと言っちゃうと
民主主義は潰れているんです
自由があるかないか なんか変な言葉で自分の主観間違っているんだから
それやっちゃうとまずいんですね
だから真理に従わなくちゃいけない
データ 事実 それに従わなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから昨日はちょっと寒かった
それは事実でしたね そうすると
春だから薄着でいようかなと思った皆様の主観はどうなったっけ？皆さんのわがままは
春だから薄着で出かけようと
これはちょっとやめてちょうだいとなったんです
ちょっと寒いんだから
もう 1枚羽織った方がいいんじゃない？ということになったんです
だからそれで真理に従ったんであって
自分の自由がなくなったというふうに言ってはいけない
自分の主観ででは主観で薄着で出かけたかったんです
で 主観は通らなくなったんですね
事実に合わせると  そういうふうな生き方を我々は毎日一応やっていますね
サンガのメンバーに自我出張は禁止なので
今 今サンガの管理は民主主義で行っています
サンガの管理はずっと民主主義で行っています
すごい単純シンプルで
民主主義といっても偉い議会を作ったり
会員メンバーたちがあって
それで議論したり  1ヶ月間ぐらいやっと決定しましたとか
そんなのはないんです
で だから理想的な民主主義ですから
至って単純シンプルでで行ってはいるんです
はい これで自我を控える人々いますね
自我張るんじゃなくて
自我を控えて謙虚に生きることが正しい生き方です
いくらなんでもそれは正しい生き方なんですね
自我があるんですよ できるだけ控えて謙虚でいようとするとトラブルが少ないんです
自分にかかってくるトラブルも少ないし
自分が社会にかける迷惑もものすごく少なくなるんです
だから 他に迷惑をかけないで
他から迷惑を受けないで生きるためには
自我を控えることなんですね
だから仏教でも仏教は無我論ですけど
自我を控えたことを控えた生き方が正しい生き方とかね
善的な生き方だとは言われるんですね
自我を張ることは ですから悪行為で生きることが苦しくなります
みんな自我を張ってね
自我を張って独裁者になりたいんだけど
それは悪行為なんですよ
やがてこの人の幸福も崩れるし
自我を張るたびに生き方が苦しくなるんです
敵が多いんです 抑えた人
抑えられた人々は気分がいいわけじゃないんです
だから自我を張れば張るほど敵が多いんです
政治的に言えば 独裁者になったら一番敵が多いんです
北朝鮮以外は世の中で独裁政権はあまり長持ちしません
殺されます 北朝鮮人は情けないですから
しょうがないんです いわゆる人間性まで潰されているんです
独裁者 強くて だから一人の人間もなんだこりゃっていうふうな意見を述べることはできない
述べたら殺されるという
そこまでやらないと独裁政権は守られないんです
だから完璧 悪行為でしょ
どれほど人間不幸に陥れているんですかね
どれほどの人間に 例えば独裁者が豊かな経済世界を作ったかもしれませんよ
作った魂はないんだけど
豊かな経済世界を作ったとします
それでも精神的に国民が惨めで奴隷精神で生きる羽目になる
だから自我を張ることがですから
仏教はあまり政治論を語りたくないんだから
我々は真理を語りたいんです
だから心理的に見ると
自我を張ることが悪行為になるんです
自我を控えることは善行為になります
自我を張らないことと無我の生き方とは同じことではありません
自我を控えましょうということを釈尊がおっしゃったのは無我ですか？違います
これ気をつけてください
俗世間にできるのは 自我を控えることなんです
だからそれで幸福になるんだから
自分が世に迷惑かけてないんだから
それで頑張るしかないんです
自分に自我があるんですよ
ある自我をちょっと抑えている
ワンちゃん飼ってるでしょ？散歩をするとどうしてもリードで抑えるんです
犬に気持ちよく散歩させません
誰も引っ張っちゃうんです
かわいそうで そうすることしかできんでしょ
リードを外して ではもう散歩してとかね
できませんでしょ 犬は人間より頭いいんだからね
そうやって放してあげたら
まあ自分適当に散歩して家に戻りますよ
問題ありません しかし
それは人間社会では 日本ではやってはいけないことになっているんです
それで考えてください
自分がすごい可愛がっているワンちゃん
ワンちゃんも楽しく生活してほしいんですね
ワンちゃんが だからワンちゃんが機嫌が良くなるんだから
気分がいいんだから では散歩に行こうと行ったら
ワンちゃんが惨めで惨めで
首にロープを付けられて引っ張られちゃって生きていなくちゃいけない
だから自我を控えるということは
そのようなものなんです
ただ ワンちゃんの場合は飼い主が首を絞めているんだけど
自我を控える人は自分自身で自分を戒めなくちゃいけないんです
それだけ違いがあるんですが
言いたいことはあまり面白くないでしょ
自我を控えることが善です
楽しくなります 迷惑をかけない人間になります
だったら迷惑を受けながらない
受けない人間になります
いいでしょ でも 自我を控える自分がちょっと苦しいんです
気をつけないと ちょっと手が緩めたらワンちゃんが逃げるんですよ
たとえリードがあっても
だからブッダが説く無我と自我を控えるということは 2つのことなんです
自我を控えることは 結構気をつけて
覚悟の上で 言いたいことはあるのに
これ言っちゃうとまずいんだから言わないというところで苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
はい その中で今自我を控える人
次にこの自我を守る人々いるんです
今 なんで同じことを違う言葉で言ったのかと
もう理由わかるでしょ？自我っていうのは良くないんです
良くない自我を控えた方がいいんです
自我を守ることがちょっとどうかなと
良くないものだからね
自分の意見を 明確に言わない
あんた これについて何か意見ある？まあね
まあいい なんでもないと
集団の決まりに真面目に従う
集団のボスがこうしますと決めたら
はい わかりましたと それだけで
学校のクラブ活動とかね
大学のクラブ活動とかね
学生に勉強できるかできないかどうで見て
クラブにクラブに入ったらクラブ活動しなさい
試験があっても試験勉強はそんなことよりクラブに朝来て掃除やりなさいと言うんですよ
学校や大学やら何かのクラブに入ったら
勉強することはもう諦めてください
学校というのは勉強する世界ですけど
だから勉強だけで何もならない
人間関係が必要です それは一番大事ですから
クラブ活動などなどは許可していますよ
結局それが逆になっちゃうんです
人をいじめる組織になるんです
決して楽しくない テニスクラブであろうが
別の別のクラブであろうが
入ってみたら最悪状態になるんです
ですから そこでどこでも見られるのは
この平和でいるために集団が決めたもの
ボスが決めたものに従います
マニュアル通りに生きる
いろんなところで我々にはマニュアルがあるんですよね
クラブのだったらクラブの生き方
学校だったら学校の 社会だったらどこでもマニュアル通りに生きてみる
周りの意見に合わせる
いつでも周りに合わせて
人の顔を見ながら 人がやっていることは意味があってもなくてもやる
これ瞑想を教える時でもよくたまたま見られますね
それで私がやり方を教えるんだけど
たまたま人が頭が申し訳と変で
言った通りではなくて変なことをやるんです
まあそれはその人がそれでいいんだけど
面白いことは 隣の人が今正しくやっていたにも関わらず
あの変なやり方に自分を変えるんです
それで後ろの人も右の人もみんななんか猿みたいに同じ
これやめなさいと私は言いたいんですよ
やるんですね 何であの性格はこの性格なんです
周りの意見に合わせる
ただ 手の上げ方 隣の人の上げ方と同じくやったということは
隣の人は自分の考えで手を挙げているんです
それで隣の人は自分で手を挙げるんじゃなくて
あ この人はこうやってこう挙げる
じゃあ私もと だから意見にアホみたいに合わせてだけです
空気を読むことに努力する
日本ではよく言われますね
空気を読むと 本来の自我
それが本来の自我を守る人々なんです
本当は最低です 自我を控えることが善なのに
この人たちは自我を守っているんです
自我が怪我しないように
批判を受けないように
他にバレないように 守ってる
でもこの生き方 すごい苦しいんです
ものすごく惨めなんです
自我を守るとロボットのように生きる人間になる
結局は人間であったのに
それは捨てたことになる
惨めに生きる羽目になる
自分で判断すること 他を導くこと
周りの 明確な過ちに過ちを直すことができなくなるんです
なんか役に立たないね
生ゴミですね 自分で何も判断しない
人は導くこと できない
人を導く場合は自分の意見を言わなくちゃあかんでしょ
それで周りに何か悪いことをやっている
どう見てもこれをやめた方がいい
この人は言わないんです
黙っているんです 意見を求めるとき
無言になる 喋れなくなっちゃう
社会の発展に良い意見を述べることも
リーダーシップも必要ですよ
結局は 国の発展 社会の発展のためにリーダーシップを持ってる人々は必要ですよ
リーダーシップを持ってる人は自我
自我が強いんですよ だからといってしょうがないんですね
必要なんです 世間の生き方の過ちがあったら
それはちゃんと判断して発表して
これはこうであるべき
こうであるべきという人間が必要なんです
自我守っちゃうと最悪
何の発展もなくなるんです
だから 結論としてね 我々はこの自我を抑える
控える人間になった方がいいんです
自我を守る人間ではないんです
自我を抑える人にとっては
まあ抑えているだけだから
たまたまちょっと緩めることできるでしょ
たまたま危険なことを見たら
これは何やってやめなさいと言えるでしょ
そういうことで 日本の社会でもね
よく見られるのは自我を守る人々なんです
無我の人々でもないんです
自我を控える人々でもないんです
そこでミステリーの自我があるんです
Mystic セルフ これは面白いです
自我という自分を持ってるんだからね
自分でもうちゃんと知ってるでしょ
おそらく皆様方はこのミステリーの Mystic セルフあることは聞いてないでしょうね
一伝統 伝統って何ですかね
昔の人々の自我で行った判断に
次の世代も従う 伝統というのはそういうことでしょう
昔からやってきたものを自分でもやる
誰も聞いたことがあります
なんでお神輿を上下に振るんでしたね
これ左右に振れとやってくれませんよ
あるいはこうやって回ればどうです
回せばできるんだけど
やらない なんで？伝統だから
お神輿は上下に振るんです
これって神が決めたんですかね
昔のアホなジジイたちが決めたことでしょ
自我で どうせ我々は 昔の世代の人々は我が強いでしょ
それで代 代さかのぼってみると
かなり我が強いでしょ
そういう人々は自我で決めたこと
伝統やという これなんでミステリーが自我ですかね
管理できない どうにもならない
我々は猿まねするしかない
それから文化 昔の人々が判断して決めたしきたり
習慣 生き方などに何のことなく従うんです
文化っていうのはそういうものなんです
まあ若者は現代文化っていう言葉も使ったりはするんだけど
でも若者にしても たとえ現代文化を作ろうとしたっても
どこかで怖いんですよ
あの人々も どこかで古い伝統
古い文化を参考にするんです
それから信仰と宗教 それもミステリーの自我なんです
人々は信仰と宗教に対して無批判的に従う
この場合はすべて強い自我なんです
強い自我が弱い自我を抑えることなんです
そこで会社に行ったら
もう気が荒っぽいボスにやられちゃって
家に戻ったらもう凶暴な母に怒鳴られて
もうハチャメチャなのに
見えない自我にもやられているんです
ミステリーの自我でもやられているんです
それを理解してください
それからまだあります
学校 社会 政府などの決まり
規則 例えば法律なども先輩の自我が現代人を支配することです
いつでもあるのは先輩人
先輩たちの自我が後輩のを抑えていることなんです
だからまあ複雑でしょ
自我の問題は なぜならば
学校に規則あってはならんと言えないでしょ
政府は法律を作ってはいけませんと言える？言えない
でも自我でやっているんだからどこかおかしい
それだけなんです 学校に規則が必要ですけど
あれ 自我の先生たちがやっているんだから
どこかでおかしい はい
それだけです はい では
後半に入ります 智慧で達するべき無我
順番に成長するべきブッダの教え
あの無我っていうのは自我ほど簡単単純じゃないんです
だから順番で休憩をするんですかね
よろしいですか 今日は始まります
はい これからお釈迦様の教えから自我はどう見ているのかっていうね
あるいは自我ではなく無我にどう達するのかということを説明していきます
だから無我っていうのはただ頭で考えるものじゃないんですよ
それはこの智慧で達するべきある境地なんです
でないとみんな自我なんです
はい それでは順番で これ順番な教えだから
順番で考えてみましょう
まあ仏教でもよく使うし
このまあプライドという単語を使いませんだけど
あのプライドという単語があるんですね
それはプライドって自我ではないんです
プライドは自我になったら何の意味もないんです
もともと自我ですからね
だからプライドという単語に 2つの意味があるんですよ
汚い自我張る意味と もうちょっと違う
悪を じゃあ仏教の定義
悪を犯す 犯すことが恥ずかしく思う
そのプライド 悪いこと恥ずかしくて誰がやるんですか
そんなのは え？そんなことやるの？という態度を取る
悪いこと それが正しいプライドなんです
それから 悪を犯すことに怯えを感じる
だから自我が強く現れる
弱く現れると 2つの側面があるでしょう
だから自我が強く現れる場合は
このプライドで誰がそんなことをやるの？そんな汚いことをやる人間いる？という態度をとると
自分が悪いことはしない
だからちょっと自我自我が強い側面なんですね
あ こんなのはやばい 悪いことするのはやばいと思っちゃうと
ちょっと控えめた自我なんですね
しかし その場合は我々はプライドというんです
プライドもいいことなんです
善行為を勇気を持って実行する
人間の中でも自我が強い人は前に行ってもうみんな強引に物事をやってるでしょ
これって本当は迷惑 自我でやってるんだから
今度はプライドでやるんです
プライドで善行為を 人はいくらやめなさいと言っても
人はいくらバカにしたっても胸を張ってやっちゃう
やることは良いことです
あんたら言うことを あんた方は言うことを聞きませんよと
かなり強い我で しかし
ポイントはやること 選んでください
善行為を 隠れてでも道徳を破ることをしない
えらいプライドを持ってるんです
道徳を破りません 隠れてでも
そんなのはプライド継続だと
これはある面で自我なんですけど
これは素晴らしいことで
自我には何の悪い影響も与えられない
人が進む道なんです ですから
自我を守るんじゃなくて
プライドを守った方がいいんです
いつでも控えて控えて生きること面倒くさいんだから
もう気が立っちゃうんだからね
なんで一生控えていなくちゃあかんのと
それだったらプライドを持てば？控えるではなくて
ドカンと前に向いて活動できます
これが仏教的なプライドですね
はい 無我に達する次のステップ
いきなり無我に達しません
1 プライドで頑張ってみる 2
理性で生きる 自分の感情に負けることも
他人の感情に引かれることもやめてみる
あ これ感情だからとか
人がギャーギャーギャー何か言ったっても
あんたほとんど感情でしょ？今怒ってるでしょ？今は欲で頭がイカれてるでしょ
ということで もう無視するとかね
それで理性で生きるっていうのはそういうことの一つと
客観的に事実に合わせて適切な判断を自分で行う
これちょっと難しい 我々は人が判断したらそれ通りにやる
人が右と言うまで待つ
道は右だと知っていても回りません
はい それから右に曲がってくださいと言うまで待つ
これは普通の生き方なんですね
だから 自我を抑えたければ
なくしたければ まず理性で生きる
その場合は判断は自分でする
例えば後ろにいる人が旗を持っている人は
ここから右だよと言うかもしれませんだけど
それを自分でも地図を地図を勉強して
行きたいところはどこにあるのかと勉強して
この場所はここで ここなら右に曲がることやと
では右に曲がりますと
それで自分自身でそのちょっとした宿題をやった方が理性が育ちます
どうせ連れて行くんだからと思っちゃうと
理性が育ちません よく学んで比較して
分析して 理解しながら正しい生き方を自分で探す
だから一人一人がそうやれば素晴らしいでしょう
私がどう生きれば良いのかと
私が私なりに正しい生き方を見つかりますと思って勉強するは
研究するは 比較してみるは
いろいろ試してみるは
生き方をね そういう風にやった方が結構立派な生きる
立派に生きられますよ
で どうせ試しだから間違いは起こります
それはもう仕方がない
あ この生き方は間違いだとわかった時点でぐるっと変えて
また研究していけばいいのです
それからどうしても自我があるんですよ
自我が発病しないように気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
皆に自我の錯覚があります
感情も主観も 自分の意見も判断もあります
だから自我があるんだから
私たち一人一人に感情があります
一人一人に主観があります
一人一人の意見もあります
自分自身の判断もあります
だから問題はあるんだけど
外を出さなくて 腰抜けて自我守りたくて出せないでいるだけなんです
しかし 自我が錯覚であることは知らない
私たちは自分に感情があるということを知っています
あなたにあなたの意見がある
まああることはあるんだけどと
それは知っています 言わないだけでね
あなたにもこれについての何か判断がある
私の判断もあるんだけどとかね
それは知ってます しかし
みんな知らないのは自我があること
自分に自我があることを知らない
それだけじゃなくて 自我が錯覚であるということも知らないんです
今怒っている 今は楽しいと感情は知っています
自分の意見 見解 判断 感情は正しいと思う
これって仕方がないことなんです
あの意図的に間違った思考をするということはできない
意図的に間違った判断しますということはできない
ふざけているとできますけどね
でもふざけていることは当たり前にふざけているんだから
真面目じゃないでしょ
だからそれは話にならないんです
あんたふざけるなよと言っただけで終わっちゃうんだから
誰だって真剣に生きてますよ
だから真剣に生きるために真剣に判断する
真剣な意見を持つ それで時々怒ったり
感情が上がったりするでしょ
みんな当たり前でしょうと
こんな環境では こんな条件では
例えば悲しい出来事が起きたら
誰かがあのね 泣いてる場合じゃない
あんた何言うのか こんなこと起きちゃったら悲しくてたまらんでしょうにと
それで相手がそこで悲しくて落ち込んでいるんじゃなくて
今大きな問題が起きたんだから
これ解決しなさいよと
人を助けなさいよと それに行かないんですね
自分が感情にやられちゃって
やっぱりその時も本人が自分の行為が正しいと思うんです
だから我々は仲間のグループで自分の意見を言ったら
その言った人は自分の意見は正しいと思っているんです
我は正しいと思うことになると発病です
もう自我が発動しちゃったんです
もう相当大変ですよ 治すのは
治せない場合もあります
だから我々は自我を手術して取り出す
前に自我が発病して破裂して膿を出して体中広がって
もう手術不可能 もう死ぬしかない状態になるまでは待ってはダメなんですから
自我を発病しない小さい状態で凍らせて凍らせて取り出すというやり方をするんです
自分の意見があるのは当然ですが
それが正しいと感じることをやめましょう
これ簡単でしょ？私には意見があります
でも私の意見が正しいということは
ちょっとやめましょう
他の人には違う意見がある
どんなことについても話し合う場合は
それぞれの人がそれぞれの意見を持っている
もう私はできるだけ この何かについての意見という場合は
1本の意見じゃなくて
できるだけ 4つ  3つぐらい意見を持とうとはするんです
大体人間は意見一つしか持たないんですね
テーマ出したら意見 1個
一つになるんです 私はそれはあまりにもまずいんだから
意見を持つぐらい持とうではないかという風に
まあケースバイケースですけどが
時々 6つ  3つ  6つ見えたり
3つ見えたり  1本しか見えなかったり
いろいろありますよ だから自我がある場合は意見があるし
その意見が正しいと思わないでください
正しいと思わないってことは
間違っているって意味ではないんです
正しくない それだけ 例えば地球は平らに見えるね
間違っている？間違っていないんです
目で地球を見ると平らなんです
まあそんな感じで平らで地球を平らで見えることは間違った視覚ではないんです
ただ 平らで見えることが正しくない
それだけ とは言っても丸くは見えないんです
そこで理解してください
私の意見はありますが
正しいかどうかよくわかりませんと
次のステップは意見を聞く
人の意見を伺ってみましょう
それに反対することも
賛成することもなく 書いていない
なぜそのような意見になったのかと
原因 因果関係を調べる
これ 皆様にものすごく役に立つポイントなんです
どんな人の意見も聞いてみて
聞く間で途中で発作を起こして相手を攻撃しないでください
どんな意見でも聞いてみてください
人の意見に対して あんた間違っている
あんた正しいって そんなことちょっとやめてください
ああ そうですか でいいんです
わからなかったらよく理解できませんでしたけど
もうちょっと説明してくださいと
で ああ わかったわかった
あなたの意見はわかった
しかし それ以上言わない
変な意見だ これは 何だ
あんたそんなにひどい意見を持っているのかどうか
それだけやめてください
意見は意見で正しいということは判決できません
それできれば立派な人間ですよ
例えば議長になってみんなの意見を聞く
60人ぐらいいる  60人の意見も聞いて理解して
なぜそういう意見のびどるのかで
因果関係まで理解するならば立派な議長でしょう
いかなる意見にも長所も短所もあります
必ず良い結果のみを出す意見はありません
難しいね 世の中で完璧良い結果を出す意見というのはないんです
みんな意見で生きている
考えて生きている 考えたら
その考えには長所も短所もある
だから正反対の考えだったら
一個実行する 両方実況できない
世の中はそんなもんなんですよ
我々は何をやってみても
ある側面で成長している
ある側面で破壊している
我々生きている世界はそういう世界なんです
あらゆる発明品が現れて現れて
携帯まで現れて まあ楽にはなっている
同時に別なところでいろんなものは破壊していくのです
このやり方で集めたデータを客観的に比較して
自分の意見を調整する
大体自分が人の意見も聞いて
そこで良いところ悪いところも調べて
どんなそんな意見になったのかということも理解して
自分の意見を調整してみる
この自分の意見を調整することには限りないんですよ
朝も昼も夜も調整しなくちゃいけない
毎日調整しなくちゃいけない
だって意見というのは完璧じゃないんだからなんです
まあ思い出した例なんで
例えばこのアラスカとかね
すごいこの北の方に住んでいる人々は
野菜なんか食うもんかと
と言うかもしれませんよ
一番美味しいのはアザラシの肉でしょうにと
脂たっぷり入っていると
あんたサラダ食べる？レタス食べる
何気持ち悪いと言われたとします
それはその人の意見 だから
その人が生きている環境から見ると
まあ仕方がない意見です
だからといって その人が言ってからと
その人の意見だからといって
レタスっていうのは気持ち悪い食べ物になる？ならない
だからごく寒いところで住んでない
野菜いっぱい出てくる環境に生まれた人々にとっては
サラダが普通の食べ物の一つで
毎日食べるのは当たり前になっている
エスキモーの人々は毎日干した肉を焼いて食べるのは当たり前で
それにレタス 1枚っていうのは考えたことはないんです
そういうことで 我々は人の意見を聞いたら
とんで正しいと とんで間違っていると言わないで
なんでこんな意見になったのかということを理解して
それは参考して自分の意見を調整すればいいのです
意見には決定はないんです
ちょっと早めましょう
世の条件 人の気持ち 理解などは常に変化して変わるんです
世の中の条件変わるわ
人の気持ちが変わるわ
そうすると意見も変わる
理解能力は変わるわ で
意見は変わってしまいます
自分がデータを参考にして客観的な意見に苦労して達しても
それは決定意見になりません
商売の世界ではいつでも決定版
決定版というものは売ってますね
1週間で 1週間でゴミ箱行きになりますけどね
もう笑ってしまうかな
いろいろなんたらなんだらかんだらの決定版とかね
だから賞味期限 使用期限というのはみたいなもの
見解にもあります  うん
その理解がある人は自我を張って惨めになることはありません
もう自我の問題からかなり自由になっています
まだ自我があるんです
あるんだけど 発動しない
だからしっかり生きていられます
すごい立派な人間になります
次に行きましょうか はい
これからちょっとステップが上がります
今まで俗世間的なレベルで喋ったんで
これからちょっと上げます
自我がある限り自由はない
世間では自由 自由とかいつでも言ってるでしょ
でも世間人間には自我があるでしょ
自我がある限り自由がないんです
他人の意見に合わせて自分を控えても
わがままで自己主張しても
エゴイストであっても
社会で存在を感じられないような
隠れて隠れた生き方しても
心は自由ではありません
ライオンのように生きていても
ドブネズミのように生きていても自由がないんです
だから あまりにも自我を張ってライオンのように生きようとする
ライオンに自由がないんです
あまりにも控えてドブネズミのように生きてみようとする
ドブネズミにも自由がないんです
中間にも自由がないんです
心は悩み 苦しみを感じるんですよ
エゴイストも悩み 苦しみを感じる
極端に惨めになっている人も
悩み苦しみを感じる そこで幸福もありません
自我がある限り自由がありません
幸福はありません はい
そこでもうステップを上げます
無我っていうこと ブッダの言葉です
無我は 例えば英語でもイゴウとかね
エゴイストとかね 単語はあるんだけど
反対の単語はないんです
無理やり作れますけど
英語じゃないんです 例えば自我にセルフという言葉を使うんだけど
セルフという単語は英語ですごく素晴らしい単語で
とてもポジティブな意味を持ってるんです
英語でノーセルフと言えますけど
え？何の意味？と 意味ないんです
英語で考える人にとっては
例えばセルフレスという単語を使っても
そんなのイエスみたいな
まあ一人だけやることやと思っちゃうんです
だから無我っていう言葉は仏教でしかないんです
それに無我とは自由への道
はい これでもう省略します
無明 貪瞋痴 感情 自我 存在欲等々がある人は
自分に 他人に 環境に依存して必死で生きようとします
みんな同じでしょ 我々は無明で貪瞋痴で
自我意識で存在欲で生きるんだから
いつでも他人に依存するわ
環境に依存するわ 有機栽培の野菜を探すわ
遺伝子改良していないね
穀物を探すわ 大変です
とにかく生きていきたいんですね
必死で生きていきたいんです
この生きていきたいっていうわけもわからない気持ちが生まれたのは
自我があったからなんです
それで我々はいつでも依存しています
しかし いくら必死で生きようとしても
命は無常で死で終わります
ちょっと文章がおかしいんですよ
どの点になってくるともうとうとう疲れていてね
でもいい加減書いたんです
命は無常なので 頑張っても死で終わります
だからえらい悔しいんです
自我が錯覚であると発見する人は無我に達するのです
そこで自我っていうのは錯覚
ちょっと頭イカれている
それだけ それを発見すると無我に達するんです
自我が錯覚だったら それに無我というしかないんです
別に無我と言わなくてもいいんです
自我は錯覚だよと言っただけでも十分です
その人は無我に達するんです
それは意見ではなく体験なんです
覚えておいて意見というのは自我の錯覚の結果です
自我の錯覚が作る汚物です
だから自我の錯覚はスーッと絶えずうんこを出しているんです
意見というのはそのうんことのことなんです
無我っていうのは意見ではないんです
あれは体験なんです はっきりと体験するんです
自分がいないと それを覚えておいてください
頭で頑張って頑張って無我を理解しようと思ったっても思考です
思考は自我のうんこです
だから無我に達するということは結構違う
敬虔なものなんです 変わらない自分がいるという錯覚がなくなることです
言葉を変えると それ変わらない自分がいるという錯覚がなくなります
変わるから自分というようになるんです
今は自分が変わらない
赤ちゃんの写真を見て
これは私ですと 若者の写真見て
これ私ですと 何言ってるんですかね
それで年寄りの写真 これ私ですと
アルバムを開けてみてください
自分の写真を 気持ち悪くなるのは私だけですかね
私は自分の写真を見るともう気持ち悪くて
なぜならば 私は今現在にいる姿だけなんです
それから変わっていくんです
はい 無我を目指す これで最も難しくなります
無我を目指すということ
それでも時間がないんだから省略します
一応皆様は仏教用語だから覚えておいてください
眼耳鼻舌身意 色声香味触法が触れる
目に何か触れる それで感覚が起きます
それで感じる 耳に音が触れる
感じるんです あ 触れたと
触れた瞬間に感覚が生まれるんです
感覚が無常なのに 因縁によって起こる一時的なものなのにです
でではなく これ間違いです
気づかない 例えば皆様はストリー見ているでしょう
無常ですよ 光っていうのは恐ろしい速さで変化するでしょう
気にしない だから光が当てて消えて
当てて消えるたびにこの自分も消えるんです
気にしません というわけで
喋るときはあの音の波ね
これ瞬間 瞬間 瞬間消えるでしょう
消えるんだから 例えば音が耳に触れるたびに
感覚も同じ波長で消えるんです
例えば 28 の音を聞いているならば
耳の感覚も同じく 28 で変化するんです
我々はあ 見えてる 見えてる
見えてる 聞こえてる 聞こえてくる
聞こえてるだけで生きているんです
聞こえてるよと なんかそれで感覚が無常っていうことを無視するんです
時々言うでしょ？いつだって見えるでしょ？と
いつだって見えるわけじゃないんです
いつだって聞こえるでしょ
はないんですけど 無数の感覚を求めて
まとめてと書きたかったんだけど
求めるではないんです
まとめる 無数の感覚をまとめてひと束にして
自分 自我だと思うんです
ラベルになっちゃうんです
本当はその中でいろんなものがあるんです
例えばでっかい透明の袋に壊れたおもちゃやら
壊れた皿やら また使える皿やら
座布団とかね ベッドシートとかね
いろんなものを入れて
缶詰も入れて クッキーの箱もパッケージも二つ四つぐらい入れて
米も 1 キロぐらい入れて
袋を閉じて どんなラベルをかける？それで看板かラベル書くんです
私のもの 私のものと袋を見たらわかりますかね
中身は だから変なラベルなんです
例えば この袋に処分するべきもの
生ゴミだったら開ける必要ないんですね
生ゴミの日は袋丸ごと外に出せばいいんです
あるいは不燃ゴミだったら
不燃ゴミ 燃えないゴミの日で外に出せばいいんです
私のものとラベルを書いたらどうする？そういうわけで
我々はあらゆる感情 感情じゃない
感覚 まとめて自我 自分
私というラベルを貼っちゃうんです
自分 自我とは 過去 現在の感情と将来期待する感情をまとめた現実ではない錯覚です
だから私っていうのは
その時 過去の感覚 今の感覚
将来期待する感覚 すべてまとめた単語なんです
ただの単語です 心のことだから概念です
サンニャーです ただのサンニャーです
だから私という単語だけ過去
現在 未来の動詞使えます
私は昔楽しかったね 私は子供の頃
結構苦労しましたよとかね
過去を当てはめます 現在も当てはめます
今はもう安心して生きていますよ
私は 今はちょっと悩みがありますよとかね
現在形も使える 将来しっかりしなくちゃとかね
将来楽しく生きていなくちゃとかね
だから 過去現在未来っていうのは
自我の錯覚があるから成り立つんであって
客観的な世界で科学世界でないんです
過去現在未来 我々には未来の杉の木を測ることはできません
過去であった杉の木はどれぐらい長さですか
どれぐらい重さですかと測ることは不可能です
今現在ある杉の木だったら
高さこれぐらい 周りはこれぐらい
硬さはこれぐらいとか言えます
重さはこれぐらいとか
だから科学世界で客観的な世界で現在しか存在しない
幻覚の錯覚の世界で過去もある
今もある 将来もある はい
この実践を観察ですよ
生きるとは六つの感覚の流れです
耳から聴覚の感覚流れる
目から視覚の感覚が流れる
鼻から味覚の感覚が流れる
舌から味覚の感覚が流れる
体から感じるか触れるという感覚が流れる
意で思考妄想するという感覚が流れる
だから六つの川なんです
互い違い 眼耳鼻舌身意
色声香味触法が触れて起こる感覚の流れです
固定した変わらない自分
自我が存在しないんです
ちょっと見てみるとわかるんです
ちょっと観察すると 例えば音を観察してみてください
で 思考を止めて 耳に音が触れる
そうすると いろんな音が生まれては消える
生まれては消える 自分の部屋に座って
目を閉じて あらゆる音を選ばないで聞いてください
どんな音でもいいんです
車の音でも 救急車の音でも
鳥の声でも 機械を動かす音でも
あのあれ 何て言いますか
ローンモア あの草を刈り
え？芝刈りの音でも ただ目を閉じて聞いてみてください
そうすると 聴覚が生まれては消える
生まれては消える 生まれては消える
生まれては消える 観察できます
そこでここに私はいる
私はいると聞いてみてください
いないんです だからなんとなく自分がいるようなんですけど
変わるんです 見ている場合も同じで
その中で実践するならば
音の方がやりやすいんです
目よりは だからただある時間かけて座って
目を閉じて聞くだけ 音を選ばない
聞くだけにする そうすると感覚が現れては消える
現れては消える 現れては消えるということを発見します
そうすると自分という気持ちも現れては消える
現れては消える だったら個体としてエージェント
メッツの 硬い自分がいないということは発見しますよ
自分の体 感覚 思考の流れなどを観察することで無我に達します
はい 自由に幸福に達します
で やりやすい方法 我々はヴィパッサナー瞑想として教えてありますよ
歩くこと ただ感覚をチェックする
上げる 運ぶ 下ろすとかね
変わるんですね 同じ感覚はリピートできません
例えば右足上げる 運ぶ
下ろす 左足上げる 運ぶ
下ろす 次 右足でしょ 右足上げる
運ぶ 下ろす でも前の右足上げる
運ぶ 下ろすとは違うんです
鋭がしく鋭く観察すると
これ感じるんです だから 1時間やるので
ワンパターンで 1時間どうやって歩くことができるのかって
みんな困ってますけど
それは観察能力が乏しいだけで
観察能力があるんだったら
え？前右足上がるでいった時の感覚と
今右足上げるという時の感覚は違うでしょうにと
感じるんです どこまで違うかというほどの言葉ないんです
言葉ないんだけど 違うということははっきりわかる
それやっていると やっぱり自分がいないという経験が起こるんです
それで無我に達したことになる
その人は自由です その人が幸福です
だから一回目無我に達したら
我々は預流果に悟ったと言うんです
その人には一切これから悩む必要はないんです
すっごくニコニコと安穏で生きられます
しかし 世の中で俺が悟った
俺が悟ったと発表することもしません
だって俺がいないんだからね
はい 以上です  あの よろしくお願いいたします
最後のあの観察のお話で
六根に外界のものが触れることで
自分がいないということを
観察することで自分がいないということを知っていくんだということで
六根の中の意に法が触れるっていうことがですね
わからなくて そこのところを教えていただきたいと思いまして
思います  あの意の  意に法が
意は何か 意に触れる法とは何か
例えばどんなことかなんか
それはもうわかりやすくするためには
この心で考えられるものすべてっていう意味になるんですね
例えば あのユニコーンのことも心なら考えられるでしょ
空飛ぶゾウのことも 頭だけだったら考えられるでしょ
だからこれキリがないんですね
過去のこと 現在のこと
将来のこと 存在すらしないこと
意で考えられます だからすべて仏教では物事という意味で法
その場合 真理ではないんです
法はその時は物事というふうに意味するんです
意で考えられるもの 妄想できることはもう限りないんです
最後の聞こえなかった
最後の言葉聞こえなかった
最後の言葉が聞き取れなかったので
もう一度お願いします
最後の言葉は何と言ったっけ？ 全然わかんないんですけれども
意というのは心で感じられるものすべて
そうはいはい  妄想  心で意に触れる
法というのは心で考えられる
妄想できるものすべてを法
まさか じゃあもう物事が法だ
物事ですよ 物事と言ったっても
ない物事も大丈夫なんです
ない物事も含まれる  含まれる
ユニコーンも含まれる
ウルトラマンも含まれる
ドラえもんも含まれる
心の中にそういった妄想の現実のすべてがどんどん浮かんでくると
はいはい  そういうのを観察することで
どんどんどんどん心に浮かんでくるものが
ユニコーンからドラえもんになったり
青い空になったり 長老になったり変化するということで
自分というものはないことを知っていく
はいはいはい  わかりました
ありがとうございます
その通りです あ じゃあえっと
先ほどの長老の説明で非常によくよくわかりました
で この頃ですね 必死になってヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっていて
自分がないっていうことがわかってきたんですよ
で 今日も長老の説明を聞いてて
自分がないということは再確認したんですが
この会場は何ですか？これ
いわゆるない自分がこの会場を見てるんですけど
これをどのように理解したらいいんでしょうかね
それはあの六 六処ね 眼耳鼻舌身にデータが触れるだけ
自分がいなくても感じるでしょ
目で感じる 耳で感じる
そこでこの会場は成り立つのです
感じなかったら会場はないんです
この会場はあるんですよね
わかりませんよ  あの 私はちょっと医学
医学のこともやってるんですけど
患者がいると思わないと治療できないんですよね
どうしたらいいかな 頭の混乱を
いえ 仮に大丈夫です うん
ちょっとまた瞑想しながら考えてみます
ありがとうございます
考える必要ないんだけど
例えば舞台に上がる人が王様の役だったら
この舞台にいる 10 分間
10 分間 自分が本物の王だと思っても構いませんよ
別に問題は起きません
10 分終わって裏に入ったらもう王じゃないんだからね
だからまあ仕事中ね このプラクティカル立場からね
現実的にちょっとあると思って構いませんね
あると思わないと手術もできないし
何もできないんですよね
ちょっとまた考えてみます
はい  えーと 前の方の方が手を挙げています
はい  えっと 質問が 2つあります
1つ目は えっと ヴィパッサナーをしていて
えっと 例えば音とか聞こえて消えるわけですけど
感覚もそうですし 例えば妄想も心に勝手に浮かんで勝手に消えていくわけなんですけれども
それを認識している 認識できるというのは
えっと 変化があって初めて認識できるんだと思うんですけど
例えば音波が耳に触れるとか
あの その変化を感じて認識しているということが正しいのだとすると
えっと 過去から今までの変化を認識しているのであって
それは例えば英語で言うと現在完了形であって
もう認識した時点では終わっているのではないかというふうに最近感じています
そうすると えっと 今というのは
感じることができない
いつも認識できるのは終わったものだけ
そうすると 過去に何かこう先人の植え付けられたものとかに従ってオートマチックに判断しているものとかを
今認識した過去のものを認識しただけ
そうすると 今っていうのは今
今を認識することはできないんじゃないかな
そうすると 認識できないっていうことは
今自分が存在しているとは言えないんじゃないかな
だから自分って今いないのかなっていう
こんなアプローチも無我に通じるのかなっていう気がしているのですが
この考えの中に間違っているところがあったら教えていただきたいというのが一つです
うん それからと  はい 最初の質問を取ってきてください
で あなたのもうあんまりにも考えてるんだからね
だから 2つ質問同時に聞いちゃうと
聞いてる人々も忘れちゃいます
私だけじゃなくてね だから人間なら考えるんだけど
その程度にしてください
もう考える方といって何の役にも立ちませんよ
だから目があるから見えるわ
耳があるから聞こえるわ
鼻があるから嗅ぐわ そんな程度
心があるから思考妄想するわ
まあだからそれに頼っちゃうとダメなんですね
だから考えたら結果が出る
考えたら真理がわかるというところはダメなんですね
今までの説明を聞くと
あんたおっしゃってる通りですよ
観察すると この終わったことを観察しているんです
音を観察するときでも
聞いて終わってから聞いたと観察するんです
聞きながら観察はできません
心に一回一つの仕事しかできません
だから聴覚が起きて それから聴覚と観察するんです
で 結局は自分がいるっていうことは
今の瞬間でわからないんです
そこで聴覚が起こる その時聴覚だけで自分がいないんです
それで聴覚が終わったら
あ 聴覚でした 聞こえた
あるいは音だとラベリングするでしょう
それで自我が入っているんです
本当は だから考えて説明するとものすごいややこしいんです
私でも哲学的に言いますよ
セルフセルフイズオールレスタンドファーストエレメント
セルフ自我っていうのはいつでも過去のものなんです
今現在瞬間でセルフという感覚がないんです
終わった出来事 存在しない出来事から自我を作っているんです
だから私の場合は そんな難しい哲学いる？いらないよ
普通にヴィパッサナー瞑想やってみてください
だからただ質問に答えますけど
私は今日体調が悪くて良かったと思いますよ
ちょっとでも体調が悪かったら
もうどこまでも哲学的に喋れます
でも私自身はこんなくだらんこといらんでしょうにと思っちゃいますよ
いいアイデアだから FACEBOOK で FACEBOOK に書こうとかね
TWITTER しようとか
絶対そんな気持ちがないんです
世界で FACEBOOK
TWITTER にあるものよりははるかにすごいことを思い浮かびますよ
絶対書きません くだらんって自分でも思ってる
まあとにかく 一つの大事なポイントっていうのは
今の瞬間で私がいないってことをね
瞬間過ぎ去ったら私がいるんです
例えば私が悩んでると言ったら
過去の出来事で悩んでるんです
私は今頃楽しいやと言ったら
過去の出来事で楽しがっているんです
ご飯食べてる時は食べることで忙しくて楽しめないんです
食べてあーごちそうでしたとかって
後から自我が入れて感情を作る
だからすべて実在しない錯覚になるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもこの過去を実況中継してはいけませんと言ってますけど
現在実況中継しなさいと
しかし 本当はあの極端な現在ではなく
瞬間過ぎちゃった現在なんです
忘れないうちの 終わったばっかしのことだから知ってるんです
それを実況するんです
例えば音 音 音と実況中継すると
その音を聞いて終わってもう死んでるんです
音が入る瞬間で音と確認することはできないんです
だからそれには我々はヴィパッサナー瞑想で
この言語を超越したレベルを作るんです
言語はいらない で観察すると直ちに解脱に達します
言語を使う時はものすごく遅くてうまくいかない
とにかく言語を使って始めてください
それでちょっと認識能力は言語なくても活動するところまで成長します
それでヴィパッサナー瞑想は進みます
はい  2番目の質問  2番目の質問はちょっとくだらなく感じてるのでやめることにしました
はい 他にあれました はい
じゃあはい この方でいいですか？ 今の話にもちょっとつながるんですが
自我とか私とか そういう言葉があるから
それがあるかのように錯覚してるんじゃないかと
だから言葉を一回は僕らが忘れた方が
長老の言うブッダっていう体験にたどり着きやすいんですか？っていう質問
ああ  でプラス でも言葉で長老は今説明してるから
僕らはその体験が差し迫って差し迫っているものをわかるという矛盾があって
それが 2つ目の質問です
あれね 言葉ってそんなに大したことないんです
私という言葉消したからといって
自分がいるという気持ちは消えません
本当はあるものに言葉を貼っただけです
言葉っていうのは本当に大したことない
だから日本語で私と言う
ドイツ人がイッシュと言うでしょ
英語で英語という言葉を使う人々は
ミーあるいはセルフと使うでしょ
だから言葉そんなに 私ではなくてXと言ったってもいいんです
それは言葉っていうのは世間の決まり
だからまあ 自分自身の命にはそんな関係ないんです
それは世間の決まり だから
私に言葉を使って皆様に無我のことを説明できます
私は世間の決まり に合わせて喋っているんです
だからあの私という言葉が現れる以前
私という気持ちがあったんです
だから言葉 そんなに邪魔にならない
言葉消したからといって感情は消えません
例えばごちそうさまでしたという言葉は日本語以外ないんです
これはどんな言語でもどう訳すればいいかと私もわからない
自分の自分喋っている言葉でも
ごちそうさまでしたは訳できません
英語ででも訳できません
しかし ごちそうさまでしたという気持ちはあるんです
自分の国のスリランカの人にでも
誰かね 本当に接待したら
ああ 良かったと気持ちはあるんです
それはどうせ英語を喋る人たちにもその気持ちがあるんだけど
単語がない  まず体験とかデータがあって
それを伝えるために仮になんかつけてるだけっていうのは言葉なんですね
そうそう 科学者よくやってるでしょ
毎日あと毎日単語を作るでしょ
科学者もやってます 研究してデータが現れたら
そちらに何か単語で止めておくんです
だから時代によって単語を入れ替えることもできます
だから我々には皆様にも日本語を全くも置いておいて
別な言語を学んで その言語で喋ることもできるでしょ
だからそれはもうそういうものなんです
経験はどうにもならん
それは先にあるんですね
はい  六種の瞑想のところなんですが
例えば耳の場合は耳があって
耳は私ではありませんと
次に音はそれは私ではありません
音の感覚が続くんですが
これを短縮して目は私ではありません
耳は私ではありませんという形に短縮しちゃっても構わないんでしょうか？それとも順番で
やった方がいいんでしょうか
それは自分にできる範囲でやってほしいんですね
パターン決めてやろうとすると
能力なかったらなんかこけちゃいますよ
瞑想ではこけたらダメなんですね
気持ちよくできる範囲にするんです
例えば耳が私ではありません
音が私ではありません
聴覚は私ではありませんとか
めんどくさくてできなくなる可能性もあります
だから自分に気持ちよく
間違いなく どれぐらいできるのかっていうところで十分です
あるいは私は今講演で説明したでしょ
何もしないで まあ音だけ聞いている
その場合 何も単語を使う必要はないんです
その時 いろんな音が入って消えて入って消えて入って消えて
いろんなイメージイメージが生まれて消えて
例えば車の音というかね
なんかぐるっと当たると
あ 車ってイメージが現れて
カーッという音を聞いたら
あ カラスってイメージが現れて消える
芝刈り機とかね イメージが現れて消える
だから実際はといったら
空気の振動が感じてるだけ
そういう風に言葉なく楽しく観察しても瞑想になります
言葉使ってもいいんです
言葉を使うとかなり正式的な
ものになるんですね 瞑想は正式的でもよろしいし
あの ちょっとすぼめても構いません
その六種の瞑想を始めたら
1から6まで全部通してやらなきゃいけないと思うんですけど
そうじゃない もうできなかったものはパスでいいんです
例えば耳だけやっちゃって
鼻はできなかったとかね
構いません そうすると何かストレスかかっちゃって
あ うまくいっていない
私はダメな人間やと思っちゃうでしょ
悟れませんよ だから構いません
一つだけでも大丈夫です ６
もやる必要は決してないんです
喋る時は６のことも言わなくちゃあかんですよ
なきゃは誤解しますよ
実際は 1本です  1本で十分です
1本もやっていろいろやってみると
自分 あ これならできる自分で発見するんです
そういうことで まあつもやる必要はないんです
一応やってみる 失敗しちゃうと
まあ一つ二つ選ぶ それだけでよろしいです
ありがとうございます
初期仏教ということで
私の方が全然受講者なんですけれども
当たり前なのかもしれないですが
ちょっとお聞きしたいことがあります
今ちょっと悩んでいるのが
友人が毎日死にたくて死にたくて仕方ないと言っています
何と声をかけてあげればいいのかなというのをすごく自分の中で悩んで
先生の本で勉強したこととか
人にはそれぞれ役割があって
それを果たすべきだとか
生命はエネルギーで続いていくとか
そういうことも話したりもしたんですけれども
その一方で 生きること自体に何の意味もないっていうようなお話もあったりもして
で 自分も鬱になったことがありまして
本当に毎日後ろから真っ黒い手で背中のように引っ張られるような
常に鳥肌が立つような
死にたくて仕方がない感覚が本当に毎日毎日続いたんですね
それで今ちょっと回復はしたんですけども
友人に対してどんな風な声をかけてあげればいいのかっていうのをご指導いただけたらなと思っております
あの人はね 欲でも自我でいろんな妄想してね
妄想 これリミット超えちゃうと壊れるんですよ
壊れたら重症でも一般の方々にこれ直せないんです
時々偉大なるお釈迦様にも治療できないところまで心を壊す
壊しちゃった人間がいたんだからね
だから今あなたの質問の中でもね
やっぱりこのいらんこっちゃ妄想してるんですよ
とは言っても 本人にそれやめられないんですね
例えば死にたい死にたいと思うのはね
あれって欲望 渇愛以外何でもないんです
生きていきたいという渇愛がなければ
死にたいという気持ちも生まれてこない
この間 私は入院していてね
もう耐えがたい苦しみがあってね
薬も効かない それで私は一人で
もう喋る能力 力もなくてね
もしかすると死ぬことはもっと楽かもしれませんよとかね
で 冗談考えるんですね
だからもう極苦しいんだけど
楽しいんです 結局は こんな死ぬ時はここまで苦しくないでしょうね
おそらく とか思ったりとか
だからこれは 死んだ方がいいかもねとかね
だって今は苦しい 耐えられないんだから
苦しみはとかね それはもうできるだけもう避けて
そういう思考をするんですね
しかし 他の患者さんとは態度は違うんです
それである患者さんがね
どうですか 痛いんですかと
本人も同じ病気でね だから私はそうなんですよ
面白くて死にそうに痛いんですよ
面白くてしょうがないよ
それはと言ったんだけど
その人 え？なんだこりゃと思って
この人イカれてるかもと思ったかもしれません
私にとっては別にそんなもんなんです
耐えられない痛みも面白くてしょうがないって
はい だからこの活はいいね
生きていきたいという存在欲があって
それも自分の計画通りじゃないね
みんな生きていきたいと思うんだけど
計画通りには生きていられない
それで嫌になっちゃって
腹が立って死にたいと思う
どんな女の子もね 白馬に乗った王子様と結婚したいんだけどね
でも一人もやったことはないんですね
それに死にたいと思っちゃうとバカでしょ
なんで私に白馬に乗った王子様と結婚できなかったんですか？とかね
もう死んでやると あまり意味がないんですね
やった人もいないんだからね
逆に言えば 白馬に乗った王子様がいた時代では
便所もトイレもなかったんだからね
面白くないんです 今の普通の人はいいんです
小さなアパートで それでお風呂あるし
しっかりした便所もあるし
王子様よりは最高です
そういうことで これまあ冗談の話じゃないんだけど
人は病気ですからね 死にたい死にたいと思うことも
生きていきたいっていうことの別バージョンでね
助けてあげたいんだけど
もうどうすれば助けられるのかとね
言葉聞いても聞いてくれないよ
また同じワンパターンで妄想する
だから一つ答え出します
その方は死にたい死にたいというネガティブエネルギーで生きているんです
死にたいったら死んで一瞬で死ねばいいでしょ
なんで死にたい死にたいと言いながら
周りに迷惑をかけながら
周りまで暗いエネルギーを発信しながら生きているんですかね
だからそれを教えてあげたらどうです？あのね
あんたはこの死にたい死にたいって
このエネルギーで生きているんだよと
だから大事にしてくださいと
それがなくなったら死ぬかもよ
マジで 言った方がいいかもね
そうすると本人必ず怒りますよ
それ怒ること必要です
直すために 向かってくること
それは必要です それに答える必要ない
それでもあなたにその気持ちがなくなったら
やること何もないでしょうねと
だってあんた漫画見ても面白くないでしょ？ゲームやってもあなたに面白くないでしょ？料理教室に行きたくないでしょ
だから他の社会活動でもボランティアでも何でもあなたやりたくないでしょ
仕事も真面目に仕事をしてね
もう苦労して仕事をして
ああ 楽しいなと思うことできないんでしょ
あなたにはと だからあなたの生きるエネルギーは死にたい
死にたい 死にたい 死にたいっていう
嫌だ 嫌だ 嫌だ 何でもという
それが生存欲 生存するエネルギーになっているんですよ
だから直しにくいんですよ
また逆に言えば ポジティブエネルギーで誰だって生きていきたいでしょう
仕事終わって楽しいんだとかね
やんちゃな子供2人来て
もうやっぱり楽しいんだとかね
...言うことを全く理解しないアホな旦那がついてね
まあ結局はいつも楽しいやと
そうやってみんなポジティブに見ているんです
世界は 忙しい 忙しい 疲れた疲れたという女性たちも
結局楽しくいるんです
生きてるんです じゃあ忙しい
じゃああんた休めと言っちゃうと
腹が立つんです 休みたくはないんです
だから人間っていうのは
たとえ忙しくても たとえ疲れても
それをポジティブに見ているんです
仕事終わって終わってみると
朝 3時やと なんで暗い人生やと思ってないんです
俺は 3時まで頑張ったよとポジティブに見ているんです
ですから 人間っていうのは普通の生き方
自分勝手でポジティブに見るか
ネガティブに見るかと
多数はポジティブポジティブで見る
世界もポジティブで見なさいと推薦する
たまたま決まってネガティブで見る人々もいる
この死にたい死にたいとね
言ってる人々は一人だけじゃないんだからね
そういう人々はネガティブで見て生きているんです
マイナスアプローチ 例えば
世界はそろそろ破壊するんだ
あと 10年で人口爆発で地球が滅びるんだとかね
神様はそろそろ現れてきて
最後の審判が起こるんだとかね
そういう怖いものを考えて
世をネガティブで見る
マイナスで見る人々もいる
どちらでも存在欲なんです
だから自分の道を簡単に変えることはできないんです
ネガティブで見る人にとっては
ポジティブに見てくださいと言ったってもね
ほとんどできませんね
ですから 結論として まあそうなんですけど
仕方がないねというところに持っていってください
まあ仕方がないね この世の中でね
答えないからね 人はがんになりたくはないんだけど
なる 年取りたくはないんだけど
年取る 貧乏になりたくはないんだけど
貧乏にもなっちゃう  そんなもんだよと
何も面白いことないのに生きていなくちゃいけないとかね
そういう風に喋ってみた方がいいと思います
ずばりこの答えという答えはないんです
難しいんです で 人間は自分の妄想はそう簡単には変えません
はい 以上です その他の質問があったら
そろそろ時間ではありますが
はい はい 言葉の機能じゃなくて
今の話だと生存欲 どうしても自分だけは生き残りたいっていう無明
自分を突き動かして生存欲が自我を強力に作っているとしたら
無我になるためにはその生存欲をなくせばいいのかなって思って
でも本当にそんなことできるのか
どうすればその生存欲
自分だけは生き残りたいという渇愛をなくせるのか
あるいはその可能なのかどうなのかと
どうやったらそれができるのか
ある意味 自我の錯覚も消えたら生存欲も消えます
だから苦しみというのは生きていきたいから現れるんです
別に流れるんだから放っておけばいいんです
だから本当に安穏になるんです
生存欲なくなったら生存欲なくなります
解脱っていうのはその境地なんです
突然俺は生存欲をなくなくしてやるっていうのはやめた方がいいんです
そう簡単では そんな楽じゃないんです
智慧 ありのままに見てください
だから 自我がどんな風にこの錯覚生まれるのかと見てみると
それ発見すると同時に生存欲もこんな苦労しなくてもいいのにってことになるんです
だからすごくものすごく気楽になる
仏典でお釈迦様の色々感想
お経とかありますよ 生存がない自分が如何に楽しく生きているのかと
ある日こう言ったんですよ
世の中で究極の贅沢で生きる人といえば
これは私のことやと 国王よりも私は贅沢やというお釈迦様は木の下で住んでいるんです
なのにコーサラ国王より贅沢やと言うんですね
お釈迦様はからかってね
じゃあコーサラ国王にね
怯えがなく 悩みがなく
1 分間いられる？ 1 分間いられるのですかと
1 分間も恐怖感がなく
悩みがなく 敵に襲われるというあれなく生きていられませんね
でもでっかい宮殿でたくさん軍人に守られて
寝る部屋にも 24時間もみんな警備やって
でも寝られない お釈迦様
木の下で横になって一切思考をやめて寝ているんです
だから それのその贅沢はかなわないと
だから存在欲がなくなるんですよ
それはなくすべきものなんです
渇愛 存在欲とも言うし
渇愛とも言います なくすべきですけど
智慧しかなくなりません
ありのままに見ない限りはなくなりません
いうことです だからいいことをあんたは思い出したんだからね
生存欲っていうのはとんでもない迷惑なんです
例えば飛行機が事故っちゃったら
ものすごく怖いでしょ
怖くなる時間がないんだけどね
すぐ落ちて死にますけど
結構怖いでしょうね 乗っている乗客は
そこで私はシミュレーションしちゃったんです
私が飛行機に乗っていく場合は
もし墜落したら まあどうせ死ぬんだからと思ったら何のこともないでしょうと
どうせ無事着陸したっても
墜落したっても同じこっちゃやと
死ぬんだから 人間は  自我があると錯覚してるから
自我を守ろうとして死にたくないっていう
それはそうです ですね
そうですね  究極の無明が自我という錯覚ってことなんですか？じゃあ
そう はい そういうことで
なんかもう超楽しい安穏な世界があるんです
はい 頑張ってみてください
どうですかね  はい それではちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
はい この祈願の...あ
その前ももう一度思い出さなくちゃいけない
今日の会場のお布施はね
これはただの物質的なお布施よりは法布施っていうね
法の真理の教えになりますけど
大泉敬さんのお布施で
あの 会場の費用ね 抑えることができましたので
心から感謝いたします
幸福になりますように
はい では 最後の祈願を一緒に御一師にとりましょう
ドゥッカッパッタ チェニン ドゥッカ
バヤッパッタ チェニン バヤ
ソーカッパッタ チェニン ソーカ
ホントゥ サッテーピ パーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
カンティ パラマン タポ ティティンカ
ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティ ブッダ